وشيعت صباح اليوم جثامين عدد من الشهداء
من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في مدينه دير
البلح وسط قطع غزه ومن بين الشهداء الذين
جرى تشييعهم الصحفي يد الرواغ وابنه
الرضيع وافراد من عائلته الذين استشهدوا
في قصف اسرائيلي على مخيم ان سرات في وسط
القطاع في البدايه اياد صحفي من ضمن
الصحفيين طق
اي الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
استهدف مكان جنب بيته قبل شهر وتصوب ب
واحد من اولاده طفل برضه طلعت امه ف على
مصر تعالجه وهذا الطفل رضيع ظل عند ابوه
هذا ظل عند ابوه وفي النهايه هي النتيجه
انه راح اياد وراحت عيلته راح اياد وراحت
عيلته من رفح ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
هشام زقوت هشام ما الوضع الان بعد يوم
دامن اوضاع صعبه وك ثيه يوم دامي بالفعل
في مدينه خان يونس على وجه الخصوص بخلاف
مدينه بخلاف مخيم النصيرات الذي استشهد
فيه الزميل اياد الرواغ وايضا طفله الرضيع
الذي فقد احد اخوته مصابا في مصر والان
والدته موجوده في مصر والان هو ظل رضيعا
عند والده ووالده نشر على مدار الاسابيع
الماضيه مناشدات من اجل اخراج طفله الرضيع
الى امه الذي كان يبكي ولم يسكت ولا لحظه
واحده من هو يبحث عن والدته لكن القدر كان
اسرع لابنه وياد حيث استشهد هو وعدد كبير
من افراد عائلته في القصف امس وفجر هذا
اليوم على مخيم النصيرات وعلى المنطقه
الغربيه على وجه الخصوص عندما استهدف
الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا المنزل الذي يتواجد
فيه اياد فقتله وقتل عددا من افراد عائلته
وبالتالي هي عمليه قصف اسرائيليه مستمره
وجل هذه الاستهدافات منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه هي على المنازل المنازل كانت
الهدف الابرز ل القصف الاسرائيلي للقصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي وايضا المستشفيات هذه
المستشفيات الان هي محور القصف محور
الحصار الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يحاصر
مستشفى ناصر ما زال يحاصر مستشفى الامل
ومركز الامل التابع للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني عمليات قصف مستمره يسمع ما بين
فينه واخرى اصوات انفجارات قويه ناجمه اما
عن قصف اسرائيلي او عن تدمير ونسف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للمنازل اما في محيط
مستشفى ناصر او حتى في حي الامل وحتى في
المناطق في منطقه السطر الغربي لمدينه خان
يونس هذه المناطق ربما الثلاثه هي مركز
القصف الاسرائيلي بخاص خاصه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يتواجد في تلك المناطق
مازال يحاصر تلك المناطق عشرات بل الاف من
النازحين الفلسطينيين ما زالوا يتواجدون
اما في منازلهم في مستشفى ناصر في مركز
الامل التابع للهلال الاحمر جميعهم
مازالوا متواجدين ومحاصرين بلا غذاء بلا
ماء بلا دواء وبعضهم مصاب ولا تستطيع الع
عائلات لا اجلاء الى المستشفيات ولا حتى
تقديم الاسعافات الاوليه اليه في بسبب
الظروف الصعبه وبسبب اصلا لا يوجد ادويه
ومستلزمات طبيه في مستشفى ناصر وزاره
الصحه تتحدث ان الدواء بات غير موجود
الغذاء والماء غير موجودان في مستشفى ناصر
بفعل استمرار هذا الحصار الاسرائيلي على
المستشفى الاطباء يعيشون ظروفا صعبه فما
بالك بهؤلاء السكان الذين يتواجدون في
المنازل هم في ظل في ظل هذه الظروف
بالتاكيد يعيشون حياه كارثيه هم يناشدون
في كل لحظه وفي كل حين تصل مناشدات من اجل
اخراجهم الى منطقه امنه لا سما وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي مازال يتواجد في تلك المناطق
التي يتواجدون فيها يطلق النار يطلق
القذائف هناك طائرات مسيره تطلق النار
الطائرات كواد كابتر باتت تستخدم بكثره
وهذه الطائرات تطلق النار على هؤلاء
المواطنين كل من يحاول التحرك حتى رغم ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ابلغهم ان ينزحوا الا ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يطلق النار من خلال هذه
المسيرات عليهم اذا حاولوا حتى النزوع
شكرا جزيلا لك من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط